passion fruit needs lots of sunlight and
rain water to grow luckily both are
plentiful here in Uganda these women are
learning to farm the purple fruit for
the first time thanks to cad africa the
social enterprise is teaching them how
to turn farming into a business we're
creating social change we're having
people view agriculture is not just
actual or like you know that subsistence
farming they're starting to look at it
as a business
so aside from teaching girls life skills
entrepreneurship financial literacy
they're looking at different ways that
they can view agriculture which is a
simple thing to get into if you own a
small piece of land as a business many
of the women working here are school
dropouts cat Africa has given them a
second chance by training them with new
skills and connecting them with local
marketplaces we have research launched
at the same time and three sites
graduate from the curriculum they
continue their agricultural classes for
the next thing is and we launched three
new sites so that these guys can start
so it's it's like a continuous cycle of
girls coming into the program we
currently have over 1,700 girls who've
gone through the program we have around
700 active girls right now but the ones
who've gone through the program are
still participating and growing passion
fruit and selling it to us before
joining cat Africa kanga Aneta earned
only three dollars a month now she's
making up to $50 a month both from
working on the co-operative and from
growing passion fruits at home she and
the other women share their monthly
income honey my Oakley moved when I have
been planting passion fruits and cat
Africa has helped me do that now I'm
part of a savings group along with the
other women I knew montedio commodities
when I get a portion of the money to
myself I will start my own project to
support myself I want to do farming
explore other business offered
or maybe do retail trading the land is
leased from a local church and cat
Africa helps connect the local farms
with market vendors who sell the fruit
after being in business with help from
local donors for four years they're
beginning to turn a profit goodbye
the biggest challenge is obviously you
know the stigma in the village that
farming is for peasants but when you
look at the reality of the situation
everyone has to eat so if you're the
farmer providing the food you will be
supplying the people so changing the
mentality of people in rural areas the
view farming as a business and not as a
chore is still our biggest challenge
despite the good conditions for growing
passion fruit in West Uganda less than 1
percent of the country's cultivatable
land is dedicated to planting fruits and
vegetables cat Africa has been handing
out seeds for local families to plant
they hope the time is ripe to give the
community a taste of the passion fruit
business